foreign
[Applause]
hey Dr John how are you I am doing great
man how are you
doing good doing good fantastic man so
what's up calling from Mexico City
what's up dude
yeah absolutely so
um me and my wife have been married for
just a short time now how long um so
about six months okay
yep so I'm American she's Mexican okay
um so we we did it for a while we got
married
um I moved here so that immigration
could be um
faster okay
um and because it was just taking a long
time so
after that we're here and immigration is
actually going a lot quicker than we
expected
so when you get married was the plan
always yo we're going to live in the
states
yeah okay
um how old is she so we we they're
basically from day one how old is she is
20 20. how old are you
21 21 where'd you all meet
uh we just met online we just met online
where was your first what was your first
meeting
uh in Mexico okay
so you met her online y'all had a couple
of times together did you move down
before you were married or did y'all get
married and then moved down
uh so I moved down maybe a couple weeks
before but not really I mean this is
living together but like in separate
rooms and stuff uh okay so um
cool so how long have y'all lived in
Mexico together now
um yeah basically six months okay
basically and you guys thought it's
gonna be a couple years and all of a
sudden it's like oh it's time to go
yeah well maybe a year or a year and a
half yeah and so now we're kind of like
oh what the heck and she really
struggles with it because she's really
close to their family yeah absolutely
like she even like
she'll get emotional it's like she
doesn't doesn't see him for like a week
or like maybe five days yeah she'll
start like crying and just be really sad
I want to see him again so I kind of
knew this day was always coming like
are you gonna be it would be really hard
but now it's kind of sooner and I don't
know how to Spur
I think first getting out of your head
this is going to be a day
yeah this is gonna be a long long long
time
okay she's gonna be grieving a
her family her culture the language the
food the smells the the Trap and
everything about her life is about to
change and she's 20. she's still a kid
yeah and
um
what I would tell you is you can't be
upset that she's feeling drawing and
Drawn to her family over this new life
that she had imagined and now suddenly
staring her in the face right
uh I would honor that distress and that
um
that apprehension it's very real very
true and she's she's going to be very
very sad she's gonna have periods of
grief deep grief she's gonna go through
periods of her feelings are gonna be
highly depressed
um that's gonna happen and it's gonna
happen for a season and so I think
settling into that's gonna be really
tough my wife
to be with me she's giving up every
thing
and so like do you get the humility
there I mean that's just such a massive
thing she's giving up all of her life
everything she knows for this dude she
met and so her body's screaming at her
don't do this right so I I guess there's
a making piece with it it just is right
and she's not bad she's not broken she's
not dysfunctional you're not bad you're
not broken this is just a tough
situation for two young two young
star-crossed lovers right
yeah
um do y'all have a moving date yet
nope we are still in the end processes
of the immigration so it's not it's not
done it's just it's just coming
when you say that are you talking 30
days 90 days six months what are you
talking about probably about 90 days
yeah okay
okay
four months I don't know okay
um question number one is I would have a
steady repeated conversation with her
probably every morning
it starts something like how can I best
love you today
yeah I had that conversation
and okay it might change day to day to
day like I need you near me and I need
to hold you right now can we do that
yeah absolutely
um I need you to get out of the house
and not look at my face cool like right
you're gonna think I thought in the
mornings we hugged today is not gonna be
that day right
um yeah the grief is gonna it's gonna be
like waves in the ocean it's gonna be
some real low valleys real high peaks
and it's going to be disorienting for
you like being on a boat out in the
ocean it's gonna feel disorienting
um just just know that's coming that way
um
I would give her a figure out a safe A
place to have safe discussions about
some very concrete plans
we're going to move on this date
let's go ahead and put one on the
calendar
what do you want to do in the 90 days
between now and when we are heading out
what do you want to do in the 70 days
between now you see what I'm saying
yeah I want to see if we can put that
date on the calendar even if it's going
to move let's go ahead and put on the
calendar and if it moves great cool
yeah
um just so it's like kind of real that
that's what we're doing we're trying to
make it very very real right now it's
still
um anxiety operates in a fantasy in this
futuristic Could Happen could happen
it's gonna happen might happen let's put
some things down and the body has a
remarkable way of responding when things
are imminent
like you hear people super anxious about
flying anxious about flying anxious
about flying
um and then you hear people who survive
a plane CR like planes going down they
don't say they were anxious they don't
say they were terrified they say they
were really sad like the body like oh
this is happening and there's there's
just ways body takes care of itself in a
pretty remarkable way let's see about
putting something on the calendar and I
would not do that and say this is when
we're going I would invite her into that
conversation yeah
um dates times on this day what time
would you want to leave would you want
to leave before breakfast or after
breakfast
would you want to leave after dinner
before dinner
um what do you want the night before to
be to look like you wanna have a big
party you wanna like let's start making
some very concrete reality and I want
you to hold some very open-handed space
for her looking at you saying I can't do
this have you thought through that
um I have a little bit what happens when
that happens
it's kind of scary to me because I mean
the same thing things that she'd be
she's going through I'd be going through
at the same time so
what's the likelihood give me a
percentage out of 100 that she says I I
thought I could make the move but I
can't
[Music]
um
okay so not a lot
no I think she'll go but like I'm not
100 sure you know
it's got to be scary it's scary to me
because I know I listen to your show a
lot so I know that she can change her
mind and that's what we discussed from
day one and stuff like it's also hard on
me yeah
um you're probably gonna feel a lot of
guilt and shame that you're taking her
away from all this stuff to go live this
other life is it you know what I'm
saying
um
I would do my best to not hold on to
that to feel it to notice that it's
there I'm feeling guilty right now
we both as as young adults agreed on
this and so
um I'm not gonna I I'm not gonna hold
shame over this I I might feel guilty my
body's gonna do what it's going to do
but we're gonna go do the next right
thing
um is there some things that y'all can
talk through about what would make
Landing in the states
more uh hospitable more of a safe a soft
Landing if you will
like the actual dare like like just
things in place I'm talking about month
one month two month three those who I've
talked to who who move
straight from Mom's home dad's home to
the states it's so disorienting what we
call normal life is so insane from the
pace and the speed and the volume and
the sound everything is madness
um yeah
soft land
yeah I definitely want to like surround
her with other people yeah from other
other Mexican people especially
um so that she can feel a little bit at
home
um and so that she like doesn't feel so
disoriented like she consider like the
supermarket the Mexican supermarket down
the street or whatever super mercado
but hold on I will do all that let me
tell you this
um
I think it's very important for you to
invite her into this conversation and as
a white American to not try to curate
her experience
okay she may come over here and say hey
the more time I spend at the supermarket
or in this thing like I can't breathe
because all I can think about is my
family I need to spend a season just
going to Kroger
yeah right um and it may be no no these
things give me
um they they let me exhale when I go
into so I would invite her to maybe you
sit down and say some of the questions
some of the things you were thinking hey
I was thinking if
we took salsa dancing lessons or if we
ate at such and such restaurant or if
you we went to a Hispanic serving church
or whatever
um that you would feel more at home but
that's just me trying to put stuff on
you what do you think what do you
think's gonna land right and you may be
all prepped ready to go and then she
goes once and she's like no I'm not ever
doing that again right and I think it's
just holding it with a really open hand
there can you do that yeah for sure so
the soft Landing would be me not trying
to curate her experience more of just
her
um her being in the conversation how are
we gonna do this yeah I think it's um
here's some here is some questions here
are some opportunities
um and maybe even
um
maybe even asking the question how how
I can work really hard like I want to
love you as best I can would love look
like me trying to find as many
opportunities for you to be both uh
culinary cultural
um education like do you want do you
want to try to recreate home here
because I'll work my butt off to try to
make that happen I'll find the the
restaurants the the supermarkets the
cultural events I'll do whatever we can
or do you want to
um
just close that door for a season that
door will open at some point make no
mistake but I want to close that door
for a season I want to jump in both feet
and try to figure out how Publix works
and why y'all driving on that side of
the road I want to try to figure out all
that stuff
um and so and just inviting her in but
but with an eagerness to I want to help
this you navigate this experience the as
best as humanly possible and I'm open to
all of it you see the the difference
there being she's not moving into
another dad who's just going to make her
do some things see what I'm saying
yeah it's very much a spirit and she may
say I don't care you do you you've been
there you do what's best you tell me
awesome say okay cool I'm gonna do this
and then in two weeks we're checking
back in
I want you to tell me everything you
didn't like about everything you did
like about it what made you gave you
peace what made you feel anxious let's
let's check back in and I think your
tendency is probably going to be to try
to own all of it you can't you gotta
invite her in and um
man I wish you guys the best I hope the
transition is going to be Rocky it's
gonna be tough it's gonna be full of
tears it's gonna be full of
heartbreak but man I hope I hope it goes
well I think is the more you keep your
hands open and the more you invite her
in to be a part of what happens next
that's the best chance your your
relationship has and by the way for
everybody listening this is for every
move every job transition every new kid
that comes along
sitting down and saying how can I best
love you in this new season and hang on
because that season's Gonna Change again
and that season's Gonna Change again how
can I best love you in this new season
and invite each other into that
conversation don't just start dictating
that is the road to transforming your
marriage